velcome Nala tilled organs pressed rev
noble family medical insensitive that
horrid or believe that a tilde Allah
noble tree seed officially Alameda scene
or Shiva Fenton Mejia helped an immense
until William C camp al-aqsa to see you
Mura federally protected
Lauren Danitra pyramid in fictional
Osaka door proceed Moscow octane Andhra
helped until juju to Varennes who
protected role and then the therapy
moved malaria the Nobel assembly at the
Karolinska Institute has today awarded
the 2015 Nobel Prize in Physiology
medicine with 1/2 jointly to William C
Campbell and support Mura
for their discoveries concerning a novel
therapy against infections caused by
roundworm parasites and the other half
to you you too for her discoveries
concerning a novel therapy against
malaria the noble facts are moon and
Karolinska Institutet at high business
on the Nobel Prize for Physiology or
medicine the CRS 5000 FinCEN so health
the combined Sam and billions example on
Satoshi
Umaga the event a common Illinois
therapy Kagan infection of shaft douche
pervasive hair Wilma also helped and you
YouTube feel even the community by NOAA
therapy Gagan malaria sofa life Lausanne
play Nobel lens to Calculon scar a
disease issue that will lock winnable
the Physiology or medicine to milk cans
but what here control tomorrow a William
Campbell
asakujaku muga political they covet
concert mom and
vote rentman concrete less infection do
you nematode percocet a Pavarotti are
you you 2% a covert concern or an oval
trademark on wet lap a ludus nobody else
here assembly up the Karolinska
Institute a relative or Nia prison each
noble F square premium of physiology
ulema designee said we to see chap did
not seek God's Agnew paavana Rovner
Williams example visitorial Maura that
cretin over therapy infects here loser
Vimal porosity cheese Kimmy shared yummy
if the royal Pallavi no jus you to that
creature Nova therapy protocol Yuri so
with that introduction I'll first show
you the price motivation in English and
then we proceed to the focus of this
year's laureates so from the left we
have William C Campbell born in 1930 on
Ireland now professor emeritus at the
dhruv University Madison New Year see us
in the middle
Satoshi Mura or 1935 in Japan a
scientist at the kid Osato Institute and
now professor emeritus at the kid
assaulted University Tokyo Japan and to
the right you you two born in 1930 in
China trained in traditional Chinese
medicine and now chief professor to
China Academy of traditional Chinese
medicine in Beijing China and with that
introduction I will present our expert
panel that will be available to answer
questions in a little while and we have
professor Yan Anderson professor Julian
Serrat
professor Hans force body all members of
the Nobel assembly Angeline seared is
also the chair of the Nobel Committee
and we will now provide a short
description of the laureates their work
their discoveries and this presentation
will be given to you by Professor Hans
force by diesel thank you
so parasitic diseases have played
humankind throughout our existence and
still today they affect hundreds or
millions of the most vulnerable citizens
of the world the discoveries by William
Campbell and Satoshi mudra have provided
us with revolutionary therapies against
elephantiasis and river blindness and
the discovery by you you too
resulted in an exceptionally effective
treatment against malaria
elephantiasis is a stigmatizing and
disabling disease of the lymphatic
system that causes lifelong swelling of
legs and other body parts river
blindness is due to infection and
inflammation of the eye
damaging the cornea both diseases are
caused by roundworm parasites that are
transmitted by mosquitoes and flies to
humans in the human body fill area a
form of the parasite migrated to the
lymphatic system causing elephantiasis
or to the eyes giving rise to river
blindness the life cycle of the parasite
is maintained by new insects biting the
human host and transmitting parasites to
new persons Satoshi Amira in Japan a
specialist in large-scale culturing and
characterization or natural products had
a vision to find aliens from nature that
could be used to develop antibiotic
drugs he was particularly interested in
the bacteria streptomyces which is very
difficult to do he collected thousands
of samples from soil and against all
odds he succeeded in culturing several
new species of Stratham users from these
he selected 50 of the most promising
cultures to be evaluated for the anti
microbial activity amazingly in one of
these samples collected next to a golf
course there was a new not previously
detected strain of slept amuses that
would change the history of medicine
Mura as part of a collaboration shipped
the 50 cultures to Campbells laboratory
their extracts of the cultures were
added to the food or mice infected with
parasites one of the extracts turn out
to have a remarkable effect killing all
the round room parasites of the world of
the mice of the mouse William compiled
an expert in parasite biology working in
USA realized that they struggled he
managed to purify the bioactive
substance and named it other mateen
subsequently the substance was modified
to a more effective compound called I
will make tea the new drug turn out to
be extremely effective against a range
of parasites in form and domestic
animals and it is today still massively
used in veterinary medicine now based on
his success
Campbell wondered whether the
spectacular effects seen in animals
might be achieved while also in humans
infected with parasites clinical trials
were initiated on patients with river
blindness and these could demonstrate
that the single dose of the drug was
sufficient to kill all round wound
parasites the journey to develop a new
drug against parasites that globally
infect hundreds or million
people had started like the previous
diseases malaria is caused by trance is
caused by parasites transmitted by
mosquitoes to humans the infection leads
to fever shivering sweating and in
severe cases fanciful itis endures
globally around half a million people
most of them children die every year in
malaria after entering the human body
the parasites first infect liver cells
thereafter they enter red blood cells
and multiply destroying the cell causing
the recurrent fever attacks the life of
the parasite is maintained by new blood
sucking mosquitos to tackle the change
challenge or developing new malaria
therapies uu2
in China trained in pharmacy and part of
a bigger national project turned to
traditional herbal medicine in
thousand-year-old literature she
discovered that the plant Artemisia
annua sweet wormwood cleared in hundreds
of recipes she therefore tested an
extract from the plant on mice with
malaria and found a clear effect on the
parasites but the results were
inconsistent too then decided to visit
the ancient literature again in a 1700
year old book she discovered a recipe
that inspired her to develop a new
method to extract the active substance
it turned out to be a great success 100%
of the malaria parasites in infected
mice and monkeys were killed this was a
genuine breakthrough
in the discovery of artemisinin and the
turning point in finding a new drug to
combat malaria the discoveries of our
McKean and artemisinin have
fundamentally changed the treatment of
parasitic diseases that affect hundreds
of millions of people the most
vulnerable people living on our planet
artemisinin saves lives of severely ill
malaria infected patients and has
markedly reduced the death toll during
the last decades ivermectin prevents the
stigmatizing and disabling symptoms of
river blindness and lymphatic filariasis
by stopping parasites from infecting
eyes and the lymphatic system in
combination with measures that interrupt
transmission via insects artemisinin and
ivermectin have contributed dramatically
to reduce the number of individuals that
are infected every year
treatment with ivermectin has even
become so successful that river
blindness and elephantiasis are on the
verge of eradication but the impact of
arabic teen and artemisinin was far
beyond reducing the disease burden of
individuals by allowing children to go
to school and adults to go to work the
treatment helps them to escape poverty
which also contributes to economic
growth of the community the discoveries
of the 2015 year's Nobel laureates
William Campbell Satoshi mudra and uu to
represent a paradigm shift in medicine
which has not only provided
revolutionary therapies for patients
suffering from devastating Paris Paris
diseases but has also promoted
well-being and prosperity for both
individuals and society the global
impact of their discovery and the
resulting benefit to mankind is
immeasurable thank you thank you and now
we open for questions in Swedish or
English get microphones
[Music]
hello mr. Irvin I'm aiming full from
China's national Xinhua News Agency
obviously we're very happy for our
Chinese scientists to win this award
this year and can you give us some
comments on the significance of mr. miss
- miss twos role of incorporating
China's Hermel medicine into this
treatment
thank you I think this is a question
that we - John yes so it was well
established even 1700 years ago that
this verb may have effects on fever but
what you two did was discovering how to
elucidate that that herb what part of
that herb actually was the biologically
active and how to elude the biological
active substance after that and that was
really a paradigm shift in medicine
allowing them for large-scale production
and clinical trials after an animal
investigation had been performed
I am Mahesh I'm from India does this
also mean that the way Western science
looks at ancient alternate medical
systems is changing
is there an acknowledgement no I think
there are many sources to find ideas how
to develop drugs and I think you cannot
neglect that there is a long experience
finding out different plants for example
so I think that can inspire us to
develop new drugs but I don't think we
are going to use the old herbs as they
are I'd like to add to that they use
very sophisticated methods to get the
active compound from these natural
products so I wouldn't underestimate
that at all and they elucidated
structures of these active agents as
well so it's not just a mix of plant but
it really is active compounds
exactly I think that's a good way to put
it it wasn't inspiration but then it was
taken through all the procedures to
really make a modern very effective drug
after that I'm worrying about the
production of our tea machine I've heard
about genetically modified organisms
that are producing the substance is that
the way it's produced today no it's a
semi synthetic production and it's still
based on the conventional culturing and
growth of the Artemisia of the any plant
yes and and there is then added to it
now the the synthetic part is a filter
activation step that is brought into it
and it's also brought into a way of
concentrating by a method called HPLC
and crystallization allowing to get
better concentration of the active
compound artemisinin there has been some
talk about resistance to this drug how
great a problem is that currently there
are the last years developed resistance
in Southeast Asia nothing in Africa as
far as we know in order to reduce the
risk of contracting more resistance it's
combined with other drugs that has other
mechanistic actions but the importance
with admission in' is the very rapid
onset in the early life cycle phase of
the malaria replication that's the
groundbreaking event that has
significantly reduced mortality in
severe malaria and that's really
contributing the artemisinin effect but
in the long run how likely is it to be
the parasite be resistant to this
compared to other drugs historically we
have always when we have developed
antimicrobial substances
has the risks of resistance and it's
really a matter of how clever we are
inducing these in more and more
combining efforts and also separated out
preventive measurements from true
therapeutic and incentive sentence and
sentence of artemisinin we should use
that for the severe cases where we have
severe cases and and in that sense
combination bind it with other drugs and
then reduce the risk of resistance
development I can just add to that I
think that is true I think inevitably
resistance will come up for for all
those but it's also important to see
what it is done for mankind
up to this point so I think we had a
question in the front row here thank you
I'm Jennifer with the tip of daily
Chinese newspaper and may ask how do you
notice yo-yo true about the rescue the
news and reaction actually as you say we
haven't been able to get hold of you
your to yet so we don't know the
personal reaction but I think for every
county that is awarded a Nobel price
there would be a positive reaction I
would hope that would be the case this
year as well but it's also that we would
do a very thorough work and go through
all the literature and we dig really
deep into literature to really find
every year the ones that have been made
the most significant discoveries for
mankind and I mean we've treated this
case in the same way that we're done
with everything before so we go very
deep into the sources
my name is Shiva gen-xer song and I'm
freelance for China radio and also
reporter for green post I'd like to ask
young understand can you tell us a
little bit about how this Satoshi Amira
and to yo-yo they cooperate today
cooperate closely or some stories behind
these tell us how do you - and how
Saturday
amaura what they collaborate i'm not i
we don't think that they do collaborate
so they've been working very independent
I can say it this way
they both use biological sources which
we call secondary metabolites
so the Septimus is soil bacteria 450
million years old and it's induced to
produce something very important in that
settings then a new anti-parasitic
compound and it's the same thing for a
dementia it's also secondary metabolites
from the heart that it's done so in that
settings that those understand that is
something very specific from a very
specific cause that's a bit we loosely
but they have not really collaborative
Airy independent separate discoveries
right for the same purpose similar to
particularly complete different types of
parasites yes but but it's in important
to emphasize that these are two
different prices that are given together
one horse is to be going to youtube and
the other half is going to William
compare and Satoshi oh yeah these are
two different parts of this price
one for worms and one for for pill to
Saguaro Plasmodium it's completely two
different sets of pathogens belonging to
parasitic disorders so there are two
different medications that have been
developed from this year's research
what's the patent situation for those
drugs okay so currently there are not to
our knowledge any patents that are up
and running so they they are not under
any patent protection as of yet
there are a number of companies that are
producing these and they are distributed
all the both these companies are
distributed throughout the world for
those in need without costs it's a very
unusual situation that major industrial
production partners have facilitated the
use by letting these out free of costs
to those that need what companies so to
our knowledge mark is a company that is
the producer of ivermectin and son
orphan about this of artemisinin
but there may well be more than which we
are not well aware of so nobody has any
patent not to our knowledge right now
and are there pending patents as you
know not that we are aware of I mean
they're on the list of the essential
medicines and so they're really
available to government and people at
need and they're at a prices that are
reasonable so they're really essential
medicines
okay are there any further questions
this is the moment there's a question
I'm sorry I was very confusing but again
about to you you can may say this is the
first time you award the traditional
Chinese medicine and can you comment the
contribution to this field yeah now it's
very important that we are not giving a
prize to the traditional medicine we are
giving rise to a person who has been
inspired by traditional manner and who
has been able to make a new drug that we
can now distribute all over the world
that is what is the prize one so it has
inspired but it's not it's not you can't
comment on the contribution to this
field by this medicine to you you're
discovered oh yeah I can it or maybe
Jana I think you have the figures on top
of yours
so these two drugs are affecting the
lives of 3.4 billion people living in
endemic areas with the risk of
contracting filariasis or or river
blindness or malaria so that is the
global situation 100 nations or at risk
of contracting them there are now about
200 million people on a yearly basis
getting ivermectin for prohibiting and
trying to eradicate river blindness and
elephantiasis there is a vast program
going on in whu-oh for reducing the
numbers of infected countries with
malaria as well and a significant
contribution has been done in whoring
the mortality in 13 years time in
malaria it's a unique historically
unique happening thanks to these two
compounds developed by
and identify discovered by these three
scientists question in the back row the
only thing I can say that we as I said
before we investigate very case very
deeply very thoroughly and of course
there are means where we can also
translate documents and there is also a
subsequent literature in English also
but you're absolutely right the first
publications were in Chinese on on the
Artemisia annua
[Music]
okay doesn't seem to be any further
questions so if not then I thank you all
for your attendance and for those of you
requested interviews there will be
information on whom to talk to and if
there are additional ones that want
interviews please contact unmarried
amounts cameras set it up for you thank
you so much for attending
[Music]
yes
professor Julien sir share the Nobel
Committee what discovery underwater this
year so this year the Nobel Assembly has
awarded the 2015 Nobel Prize to William
si Campo and Satoshi
amaura for their discoveries concerning
a novel therapy against infections
caused by roundworm parasites that's
jointly and the other half is to to you
you for her discoveries concerning a
novel therapy against malaria I was at
the press conference and it was a bit
quiet it seemed that people will not
expecting this price why is that
well probably as you know the Nobel
assembly and Nobel Committee we keep
most of our work very secret and so for
me as chair of the committee I'm always
quite pleased when people are surprised
that means we've done our work well and
every year we get between 300 and 400
individuals nominated and so in some
ways it's be very difficult to almost
guess who the laureate might be with
that many individuals nominated each
year so I think I'm pretty happy that it
was a surprise the really often Nobel
stated that the prices should be awarded
to those who have confer the greatest
benefit of mankind so how does this
prize fulfill this criterion well I
think these two discoveries are a really
good example of conferring the greatest
benefit to mankind because both of these
discoveries have led to therapies that
are against parasites so camp a little
more their discoveries have led to drugs
that are used now to treat roundworm
infections and this is causing diseases
like elephant kisses and river blindness
those two diseases are really
debilitating people have lifelong
suffering because of those
Jesus and this drug therapy now can
reduce the the disease you u2's
discoveries have led to drugs against
the malaria parasite and that is also
save the lives of millions of
individuals so within the idea of Nobel
I think we have examples here that have
conferred the greatest benefit to
mankind
you know these therapies they save lives
they prevent disability and they prevent
the spread of infection and they also
improve the life well-being of
individuals and economic growth so I
think this is a great example
well Nobel would have been happy and why
was the prize awarded now why do I this
way this year well you know every single
year we start with the new plates and
the committee and the assembly have been
working very hard going through the
nominations and we came to the
conclusion that this was the best you
know constellation the best prize this
year and that's why we're here to talk
about these lawyers what are the key
breakthroughs that make these laureates
worthy of Nobel Prize I mean who did
what so you have to think of it as two
parts so amaura was working in Japan and
he was really interested in identifying
microbial and it might microbe
antibiotics so he went to soil and he
had a hypothesis that he would be able
to collect soil samples and they would
have bacteria that would ward off
infection and so he collected soil
samples and cultured them in his
laboratory and he looked for samples
that had unusual properties and that he
then selected from thousands of cultures
about 50 of these samples that he sat on
and kampl could take these samples and
give them to animals to mice they took
life alized broths
from these samples mix them in the food
of mice and they could find that they
had anti-parasitic effects they could
kill parasites in mice campo also took
these compounds and he tested them in
lives
and farm animals in cattle poultry
domestic animals dogs and he could show
that these compounds could killed Ronald
Warren parasites
he also Campbell could show that there
was durability that one dose of this
compound was sufficient to kill
parasites for up to a year these
experiments these discoveries led to the
clinical development of a drug called
ivermectin and that was used later to be
able to treat people who had river
blindness uu2 she was part of a larger
project the project had probably little
little progress but she came on the
scene she took the challenge of turning
to traditional Chinese medicine and she
was surveying different plants for their
active compounds against malaria and she
identified one plant Artemisia I knew
that was effective against killing the
malaria parasite but initially her
results were mixed so she went back to
very ancient Chinese literature 1700
year-old literature and she got Clues on
how to refine and work with her
extraction procedures and from that she
was able to identify an extract that was
a hundred percent efficient in killing
the malaria parasite she then went on
and tested that in bunkies and later in
humans so this considered a breakthrough
at a time when this findings were
presented sort of I think they you know
they were because they were so
efficacious so they were seen as a
breakthrough now admittedly the work of
uu2 was largely seen in China and that
really came to the Western world some
years later but it was clear that both
of these compounds ever met in first
with Campbell and artemisinin with you
you too were seen to be very effective
in killing parasites one was killing
wrong parasites the other one of the
malaria parasite cysts are a lot of
young people watching right now and how
explained in an easy way to the
importance of this France to a grade
school student I took it down to the
grade school level you can imagine that
if you are going to go on an African
safari you're going to go to the
tropical regions of the world where
these parasite infections are very
prevalent you would take along your
mosquito net you take it along your bug
sprays but you may still get bit by a
fly or a mosquito that might transfer
either the roundworm parasite or the
malaria parasite to you if that would
happen you would become very ill because
of these drugs we now have therapies
that kill these parasites very early in
their lifecycle
they not only kill these parasites but
they stop these infections from
spreading so it's it's one way to kill
the parasite another way to stop it from
infecting other people now if it turned
out attention to the laureates who are
they okay Toshio Morra is still active
he's working in Japan
he's a microbiologist and he really had
a long history in working with soil
samples and bacteria and trying to
identify active compounds from bacteria
that could be efficacious he's still
active as a scientist today William
Campbell he's a parasite ologists he's
retired he's less active scientifically
but he had a long-standing career
working towards developing antibiotics
for the livestock industry and was
really instrumental in taking these
therapies towards the clinic with his
other collaborators you know to again I
believe she's retired but um she's in
Beijing China at the China traditional
medicine Academy and had worked for many
many years
utilizing traditional Chinese medicine
and finally custom alchemists had been
able to reach any real audience so urban
has been successful in contracting
um dr. Elora this morning he was
delighted and he was very pleased to be
awarded the prize together with William
Campbell he thinks he's a very nice
person he's really excited about this
this joint award we have not been in
contact with William Campbell nor have
we had contact with to you thank you